et rémy bourgade le directeur technique
du théâtre de montpensier nous a
rejoints sur ce plateau nous allons
ensemble parler donc des journées du
patrimoine puisque j'ai regardé le
programme de versailles est tout de
suite premier coup de coeur j'ai vu que
le théâtre de montpensier ouvrait ses
portes mais alors on est là du tout à
leur patrimoine caché ça veut dire que
on va en fait voir ce qu'on ne voit pas
d'habitude tout l'envers du décor
absolument c'est la façon cachée de
l'iceberg donc grosso s'est plu à
l'envers du décor des vrais beaucoup
justement le public y voit que la scène
en tout cas se présente sur scène donc
là on va l'emmener dans un parcours qui
va nous permettre de voir l'entrée des
coulisses petit peu la vie des artistes
à l'intérieur puis passer sous la scène
voir là les tripes de
du théâtre nous avons la chance d'avoir
un théâtre du xviiie
je me plais à dire que c'est le premier
théâtre de comédie construit en france
avec une machine rire italienne donc des
dessous des centres des coulisses et on
a un programme depuis quelques années de
réhabilitation de cette machinerie
pas dans pas dans les formes anciennes
mais c'est avec de l'acier quand même
mais c'est la même fonctionnalité donc
ça nous permet de faire des changements
de décors apparition disparition de la
georgie valencien dise pas que le public
va voir 7,7 cet ensemble de machinerie
passer sur la scène se rendent compte un
petit peu de ce que c'est que de voir le
public quand on est sur scène et puis
voir les différents espaces qui ne sont
réservées à des quotidiens le dessous de
scène qui a été restauré un vous désire
non mais passe en dessous alors on a pu
voir a dit mme beaudin sur la vidéo qui
travaillent avec vous tapez de
montpensier elle nous a fait la petite
visite on passe vraiment sous la scène
en fait c'est très impressionnant on
voit les différents mécanismes et là par
exemple on voit un petit trou sur sur la
scène qui donne accès directement en
dessous c'est avant les bandeaux un thé
seront valables pour la visite si
justement il faut pas que les gens
tombent dans le groupe oui c'était bien
de l'accident on a mis des protections a
fait un petit peu protection chantier et
parce que c'est effectivement aux
visites quand même notre chantier c'est
notre gentil par mano jusqu'à là vous
même pour guider je ne serais pas là non
mais il y aura des hôtesses d on a fait
une petite mise en scène ya des gardiens
de musée qui sont là assis sur leurs
chaises qui surveille les visiteurs et
puis donc tout est fléché et le parcours
aura des panneaux annonçant
ce qui se voit et puis aussi un peu de
terminologie parce qu'il nous engage un
peu particulier et on peut donc la
rentrée les mots c'est un exemple j'ai
envie de vous demander ce que c'est
qu'une servante au théâtre la servante
c'est un
moyen d'éclairage qui oppose sur scène
qui est allumé 24 heures sur 24 pour que
le théâtre ne soit jamais dans le noir
alors on voit ici à de petites taches de
lumière et pourquoi parce que justement
dans un théâtre de heurts des trous qui
ceux qui ont été laissés par des
éléments du décor si on fait le noir et
que quelqu'un rentre dans cette salle a
ou sur scène en tout cas il peut se
cogner tomber donc on a depuis très très
longtemps je ne sais pas si c'est depuis
l'origine mais on a fait ça mais ça
c'est quand même une explication très
rationnel parce que moi j'ai entendu
parler de superstition est apte à porter
un peu malheur de laisser un théâtre
comme samuel noir moi je suis pas
superstitieux dj moody petit sur des
théâtres c'est vrai qu'il ya des mots
interdits vermont mais je ne m'interdis
pas de les dire enfin cette partie là du
patrimoine j'aurais demandé à nos deux
autres invités si c'est quelque chose
qui vous intéressent aussi parce que le
patrimoine c'est très très large on l'a
vu des bâtiments théâtre également et
les coulisses donc à découvrir du côté
de montpensier c'est un pan de
l'histoire du patrimoine qui vous
intéresse parce que je crois que si on
est curieux de nature et l'histoire ou
la pas très loin de nous intéresse si on
n'est pas curieux d'aller au théâtre
alors ce que vraiment on enlève une un
pas notable de tout notre patrimoine
intellectuel c'est à versailles je
dirais le théâtre montansier pour moi
c'est un s'est pas cachée c'est c'est
presque un début d'aller vers le château
de cette montée de la situation même du
théâtre montansier mérite le détour et
merci de nous ouvrir la journée du
patrimoine ah non moi la curiosité du
deus ex machina tout de suite la
traduction en français les jeunes
s'avèrent les machines apprend beaucoup
de choses ce soir marie de ré et
stewards pour le musée de la ville même
chose - rhodia théâtre à 50 ans
d'ailleurs nous propose ici la visite de
saint quentin donc voilà on peut faire
les deux visites
place sur sa de 50 amis
mais nous faut vraiment dépêcher de
réserver mais oui bien évidemment que
j'ai vu que le terrain fait partie de
notre patrimoine est aussi bien le décor
la coquille du théâtre que l'ensemble de
des écrits et de ce qu'il est face à des
parties de ne pas traîner car notre seb
récents comme celui de saint quentin en
yvelines justement la construction est
quand même plus récentes et aux 6,7
cette histoire qui s'en dégage alors
c'est mieux on sent l'histoire de wii
tennis open puis contemporaine mais bien
plus c'est une histoire où on va on
prend beaucoup de reprises qui vont
venir des scènes parisiennes et c'est
donc c'est quelque chose de relativement
différent du tableau ancien qui a quand
même cette histoire avec un grand h fait
que nous malheureusement retrouve pas
ces complémentaires voilà pour qu'elle
ait visité les dossiers ce week-end pour
les puits des programmations sont aussi
différents donc c'est allé voir les deux
mais ça fait depuis 2009 1 que le tête
de mon temps ci n'était plus ouvert pour
les journées du patrimoine vous vous
recommencez est ce que vous auriez une
anecdote comme ça à nous raconter parce
que sa fille à bord et puis le nom
d'année vous travaillez vous devez bien
avoir les petites anecdotes et non sur
console et moi je suis technicien alors
c'est vrai que j'ai pas la facilité de
wotan dernier texte dire je retiens très
mal les textes mais non on fait un peu
heureux pour eux comme ça non je
n'aurais effectivement plein d'histoires
je serais incapable de vous en sortir
une comme ça mais c'est vrai que comme
on disait tout à l'heure la similitude
avec les théâtre moderne c'est comme une
famille et le terme au théâtre parce que
j'allais dire c'est l'aspect humain
comme absolument toute une équipe
derrière en coulisses qui travaillent
oui on est assez soudé et puis toutes
les aventures selon les porte on peut
dire n'est pas isolé donc des anecdotes
comme ça non j'aurais du mal à vous en
sortir comme ça en tout cas on aura
appris la servante que c'est comme ça
contre les possibles au niveau des
horaires de visite alors qu'en fait
c'est 10h 13h 14h 17h d'accord vous
soyez à l'heure c'est la conservation
sans réservation merci un ami me regarde
merci à marie le reste ignares et à
françois boulay merci à tous les trois
d'être venu parler des journées du
patrimoine ce soir sur tv filles vous
découvrez les richesses du département à
quelques jours du grand rendez-vous du
patrimoine en france et en europe les 15
et 16 septembre et puis je vous rappelle
aussi que cette émission comme toutes
nos archives sont consultables ça fait
partie du patrimoine également sont
consultables sur notre site internet
vont nous rejoindre est pour les 15
dernières minutes de cette émission est
des passionnés d'histoire également ce
sera juste après un détour par la
chaufferie de versailles jaune oui un
lieu étonnant qui dénote un pour
versailles un autre coup de coeur je
vais vous emmener sur un site industriel
celui de verser aux il s'agit du
chauffage urbain de la ville de
versailles
voilà donc en fait on a les gaz chauds
qui sortent de la cour ont mis à sa fin
christian pontonniers travaille depuis
32 ans dans les chauffage urbain depuis
six ans il exerce sur le site de
versailles un lieu caché qui ouvrira au
public lors des journées du patrimoine
en avant-première christian pontonniers
nous emmène en visite guidée
on a donc trois chaudières pour le
chauffage urbain ces trois chaudières
gaz
qui nous permettent d'assurer la
production de chauffage et d'eau chaude
sanitaire sur l'ensemble de chauffage
urbain aussi surprenant que cela puisse
paraître la chaufferie versaillaise
participe depuis trois ans aux journées
du patrimoine le site industriel se
distingue ainsi des deux rives
historique proposée par la ville je
crois que les gens actuellement sont
très intéressés justement par des sites
industriels et puis il faut bien savoir
que cette chaufferie fait partie du
patrimoine de la ville puisqu'elle
appartient à la ville de versailles il
était donc normal de l'ouvrir de façon à
ce que les versailles et et tous les
autres puissent une humanité et parmi
les nouveautés de l'année 2012 cette
turbine à gaz qui fonctionne cinq mois
par an et produit 95 mille mégawatts
ça c'est une turbine et l'ensemble du
système c'est un système de cogénération
la société de chauffage versées aux
succursales de cofely dispose d'un
réseau de 27 kilomètres pour 90 points
de livraison d'énergie elle alimente le
centre de versailles et le plateau de
satory
le public pourra découvrir le site
industriel samedi 15 septembre de 10h à
16h30 pour les journées du patrimoine